Are you familiar with factor five clotting disorder?
Yeah, that's a little, I think that's a little lightens disorder.
If so, how do you treat it and keep a patient from clotting?
What's the effectiveness of natto kinase versus lumbar kinase, et cetera,
for something like this?
So, typically a person doesn't even know they have that until they end up developing
some clots, and then they may be screened for that.
If they developed, let's say, deep vein thrombosis,
this is the second time they've developed it, then they may get screened for that,
and they find out they have it.
So factor five is a genetic mutation.
You can have a single or double immune, double allele defect on that gene.
People with a double allele defect, we're going to have even more difficulty,
and they will develop more clots, at least have the chance of it.
People have difficulty in pregnancy having that factor.
So if they've ever had clot formation during pregnancy, they will be watched and screened for that.
I think from a medical standpoint, unless you have a history of having clots,
they're not going to necessarily recommend you go on a drug for this,
unless you're having issues.
Plus, I think it depends on other factors, other cool morbidities,
this person of high cholesterol issues, are they worried about possible heart issues?
Do they have a history of heart attack, a history of cardiovascular disease, things like that?
From a natural perspective, so what are your best anti-clotty things from a natural perspective?
Garlic.
So garlic is going to be your best blood thinner.
Your Omega's can be decent blood thinner as well.
Things like curcumin can be a slight blood thinner.
Garlic is going to be by far your best blood thinner.
As far as what can gobble up clots, dado kinase, lumbro kinase,
are your two enzymes that you'd use to gobble up clots.
There's some thought that just high dose enzymes in general can be beneficial,
but those two enzymes would be the best.
So if I do, I had that disorder, I'd be taking a product with dado kinase and lumbro kinase in it.
This is a common concern since the certain, you know, what came out after that certain, you know, what disease came out a few years ago.
And when they came out with the correction before that that involved a needle.
People are having all sorts of clot formations.
So using a dado kinase, dado lumbro kinase product, using garlic can be extremely beneficial as a preventative measure for those people.
The only thing that I'd say, you know, you can't really hurt yourself, taking garlic in these enzymes,
unless you are on a blood thinner.
So the enzymes are fine, even if you're on a blood thinner, but taking excess garlic, if you're on a medical drug blood thinner, you really got to watch because garlic, garlic works really well.
And I know people that got off their blood thinners because they didn't want to be on a medication anymore.
So, so they, they used garlic instead.
So, you have to be careful, doubly dumb.
So if you're on a medical blood thinner drug and you're using garlic, you better be very leery of, you know, excess bleeding, you know, easy bruising and all that kind of stuff.
But what's worse, having a little bit of easy bruising and capillary fragility and, you know, that's not going to really kill anybody unless they end up with a bleed or if they have an ulcer or something like that versus a blood clot.
So you do have to be, you have to weigh that out.